phoenix runde
schönen guten abend und ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen hier im studio begrüße
ich georg streiter er war von 2011 bis
2018 stellvertretender sprecher der
bundesregierung für fdp und csu und er
ist jetzt berater und blogger und
twitter auch fleißig und frank stauss
ist bei uns seit vielen jahren ist der
wahlkampfmanager unter anderem für klaus
wowereit malu dreyer und auch olaf
scholz aber eben nicht in diesem jahr
und seine erfahrungen von über 30
wahlkämpfen sind nachzulesen in seinem
buch höllenritt wahlkampf herzlich
willkommen dankeschön zugeschaltet ist
uns ben folds er ist fernsehredakteur
des norddeutschen rundfunks und hat
gemeinsam mit philipp grill drei lange
porträts gemacht von laschet scholz und
baerbock mit dem titel die wollen da
rein das finden sie in der ard mediathek
genauso wie die phoenix runde übrigens
und ich begrüße jasmin riede sie ist
politikwissenschaftlerin der universität
der bundeswehr in münchen einen guten
namen professor
guten abend herr streiter sie haben in
ihrem blog geschrieben dass es ja sein
könnte dass angela merkel möglicherweise
eine siebzehnte neujahrsansprache halten
muss wie kommen sie denn darauf
weil ich mir vorstelle und langsam
nähert sich meine vorstellung und die
realität einer nah an das ist eine sehr
schwierige regierungsbildung werden
könnte nach der bundestagswahl wir haben
zum ersten mal eigentlich die situation
dass man mit knapp über 20 prozent eine
wahl vielleicht gewinnen kann
wir wissen nicht wie es am wahlabend
aussieht vielleicht gibt es ja
22 menschen die die führung beanspruchen
und sagen jetzt führe ich mal gespräche
und das kann also eine weile dauern und
nach der letzten bundestagswahl
da war es so dass vergebliche jamaika
verhandlung geführt wurden dadurch wurde
es ein bisschen aufgehalten aber es hat
dann bis märz gedauert warum sollte es
nicht bis januar dauern aber sie glauben
nicht dass angela merkel noch einmal
eine ganze legislaturperiode hängt
robin ist vorbei ist
wenn man diese umfragen wie die spd
steigt und steigt in den umfragen das
hätte man ja vor einigen monaten
überhaupt noch nicht gedacht oder vor
wenigen wochen noch nicht gedacht was
kann jetzt olaf scholz eigentlich noch
gefährlich werden das ist eine sehr gute
frage weil wir ja normalerweise diesel
diese umfragen die allgemeinen um fragen
die uns die in den wasserstand zeigen
die folgen ja meistens auch noch anderen
umfragen die im parallel erhoben werden
zum beispiel zur
problemlösungskompetenz oder zu der
frage welche person hat die höhere
kompetenz ins kanzleramt zu kommen unter
all diesen fragen also auch diesen
zweiten und dritten reiten fragen liegt
die spd im augenblick zu das heißt man
kann eigentlich davon ausgehen das da er
noch ein zuwachs kommen wird auf der
seite ansonsten also eher kündigen
können
davon gehe ich heute aus europa der
kanzler wird das hängt ja dann wieder an
dem koalitionspoker aber natürlich hat
die spd zum ersten mal
seit den letzten drei bundestagswahlen
überhaupt wieder mehrere machtoptionen
das ist ja das entscheidende was ihr
gerade so hilft die hatten weder
steinbrück noch steinmeier
noch schuld weil zu dem zeitpunkt wo wir
gerade sprechen war bei den letzten drei
wahlen klar angela merkel bleibt
kanzlerin in welcher konstellation auch
immer jetzt ist eben nicht klar wer es
wird aber die spd hat mehr option also
über diese machtoption reden wir
natürlich auf jeden fall herbold sie
haben die drei kandidaten ja beobachtet
gemeinsam mit ihrem kollegen philipp
gröber eine längere zeit wenn wir über
machtoptionen reden und auch die frage
nach dem machtwillen ihre dokumentation
ist die wollen da reihen haben sie den
eindruck dass jeder von den wirklich da
rein will und auch einen ähnlichen
machtwillen hat
also ich glaub olaf scholz hat von den
dreien glaube ich den ausgeprägten
machtwillen aber armin laschet glaube
ich fast genauso
annalena baerbock hat den auch also
letztendlich bewirbt man sich ja um
dieses amt oder auch dieses amt um
bundeskanzler oder bundeskanzlerin zu
werden insofern würde ich sagen alle
drei haben diese machtwillen bei olaf
scholz ist er sicherlich am
ausgeprägtesten auch was das macht
strategische angeht und zudem max at
gischen heißt auch die machtoptionen
immer mitdenken also was haben konnten
sie dabei urlaub falls was raus finden
also dass klar ist mit wem er auf jeden
fall gerne regieren möchte ist ja
bekannt dass er am liebsten mit den
grünen regieren würde zu der zeit wo wir
mit ihm gedreht haben wir haben ja so
bis anfang august mit ihm gedreht da hat
sich die frage dass er bundeskanzler
wird noch nicht so wirklich gestellt da
war die spd in den umfragen begann sie
so langsam leicht zuzulegen aber da lag
sie noch immer so bei 15 16 prozent
insofern war das noch nicht so ganz
realistisch dass olaf scholz unbedingt
bundeskanzler wird er hat zwar immer
davon geredet aber so richtig geglaubt
hat dass bis dahin erst mal niemand so
und das hat sich dann in den letzten
wochen ja anders entwickelt frau riedel
was denken sie dann ist das rennen schon
gelaufen jetzt zweieinhalb wochen vor
der wahl
na ja es wird also zumindest deutlich
enger und was mir eigentlich immer
wieder aufgefallen ist in den
vergangenen monaten ist dass die
stimmung innerhalb der wählerschaft doch
so sehr volatil ist sehr wackelig ist
und man konnte das zum einen könnte man
das auch lange noch so ein bisschen
positiv aus legen also in dem sinne naja
armin laschet hat ja noch die chance das
ruder rumzureißen weil es sind ja noch
ein paar wochen hin und es gibt noch
unentschlossen und den punkt würde ich
jetzt an der stelle aber so nicht mehr
machen weil sie haben gesagt es sind nur
noch zweieinhalb wochen je nach umfrage
galoppiert die spd und vor allen dingen
natürlich olaf scholz der union ziemlich
davon und armin laschet ja der reitet
sich eigentlich so von einem problem ins
nächste also alles was er macht wird ihm
irgendwie auch so ein bisschen negativ
ausgelegt also das zukunftsteam so als
letzter rettungsanker dass angela merkel
sich jetzt für ihn einsetzt nochmals
letzter rettungsanker und dann diese
querelen auch mit mit markus söder wo
jedes wort von söder auch so ein
bisschen als ironische stichelei
interpretiert wird also hat es da schon
sehr schwer das ruder noch mal
rumzureißen
er hat schwer und das klingt so als wäre
die cdu würde sie sich selber eben diese
probleme bereiten herrscht reiter jetzt
haben wir gestern die kanzlerin gehört
in der bundestagsdebatte wo sie eben
sehr klar für armin laschet geworben hat
das war ungefähr durch diese
wahlkampftöne oder sie kennen ihn angela
merkel länger ich war das dann war das
eine ungewöhnliche auftritte weil es ist
so so die ist die not so groß dass sie
das tun musste ja das hat sich früher
auch schon getan da wollte sie aber
wieder bundeskanzlerin werden in diesem
fall ist es eben als überraschung
wahrgenommen worden weil nicht die
bundeskanzlerin werden will sondern weil
sie armin laschet
dass ein bisschen leichter machen wollte
dass man das sonst eher zurückgehalten
hatte ich vorher sehr zurückgehalten und
das haben wir auch viele beklagt und ich
glaube sie hat damit auch vielen vielen
partei anhängern von cdu und csu einen
großen gefallen getan hat weil es auf
der anderen seite ja auch so kampagnen
gab wie die welt sich überhaupt cdu ja
und will sie überhaupt dass laschet das
wird also das war glaube ich
innerparteilich und parteien hygienisch
irgendwie notwendig und auch gut der
nicht meine warum soll sich das nicht im
bundestag machen und ich denke sie wird
sich auch in den nächsten in den
verbleibenden tagen auch stärker
einbringen als sie das ursprünglich
gedacht hatte
weil sie will natürlich auch nicht in
die geschichte eingehen als diejenige
die
die tu ruiniert hat ja so dass werden ja
die geschichte wird hier dann danach
erzählt werden falls die ware dann im
moment verantwortlich dafür dass die
umfragen so schlecht sind
also ich glaube wenn ich mir auch keine
nicht viele freunde mitmachen aber ich
glaube das sag ich mal die hälfte der
verluste der union auf das konto von
markus söder gehen und dann der csu die
das einfach nie verkraftet haben
dass sie nicht so als erster gefragt
wurden kann man auf das war aber auch
gar völlig klar dass sie das nicht
würden ja und und sie hätten das halt
die grünen haben das ja vorgemacht wie
das geht ja dass man also relativ
geräuschlos die sache geklärt und dann
ist ruhe also ich habe robert habeck hat
einmal ein bisschen schmerzen geäußert
und das war's und
markus söder bis heute ja bis heute
morgen hat er doch wieder irgendwie
sich bei einer lustig gemacht über die
cdu das macht man nicht das ist
ungewohnt kollegial und wie man jetzt ja
auch in umfragen in bayern sieht schade
dass auch in bayern nach der nach
letzten umfragen von infratest dimap
kommt er so nur in bayern kommt die csu
auf 28 prozent die spd auf 18 grüne auf
16 fdp auf 12 frau riegel sie sind ja in
münchen ist wie würden sie es wie sind
die die ist die stimmung da haben sie
den eindruck dass die csu hat eben
wirklich keine ruhe gibt und dadurch
dass armin laschet immer noch so schwer
macht wurden sie herrn streiter da
zustimmen
ja ich würde herrn streit hat schon
zustimmen also zumindest hätte markus
söder die möglichkeit ein bisschen
ruhiger noch zu sein und nicht doch noch
mal das eine oder andere verschmitzten
grinsen bei einer frage beantwortung
somit schwingen zu lassen den den
eindruck habe ich schon und hinzu kommt
also sie haben jetzt auch die
umfragewerte auch in bayern noch mal
angesprochen es ist auch schlichtweg so
die bürgerinnen und bürger die mögen es
nicht wenn die parteien sich intern
streiten das haben wir in der
vergangenheit in den vergangenen jahren
zu genüge gesehen bei der spd jetzt
sieht man es bei der union bei der union
hatten vorher auch schon zum teil
gesehen und es ist tatsächlich so dass
diese interne aushandlungsprozess diese
kandidaten
streitereien zwischen söder und laschet
aber natürlich auch zwischen und
zwischen der cdu und der csu
die haben jetzt dem wahlkampf nicht
gerade geholfen und den umfragewerten
der union nicht gerade geholfen
herbold ich würde frau riedel da
unterstützen wollen auch noch mal vor
dem gesichtspunkt dass die cdu es bis
heute nicht geschafft hat über themen zu
reden also die gesamte zeit wo wir auch
mit armin laschet gedreht haben war es
eigentlich immer so dass wir nur über
die csu und über markus söder gesprochen
haben und die neueste attacke die markus
söder dann wieder geritten hat als
beispielsweise das wahlprogramm
vorgestellt worden ist dann wurde immer
so getan als wenn man irgendwie gut
freund mit einander aber direkt in der
pressekonferenz gab es dann wieder
irgendwelche sticheleien und ging es hin
und her und so war es ja die ganze zeit
und ich würde in einem punkt
widersprechen wollen ich glaube auch
dass die unterstützung von angela merkel
jetzt im bundestag eigentlich zu spät
kommt also die hätte wählen früher
kommen müssen dass sie jetzt gekommen
ist zeigt eigentlich nur wie dramatisch
die lage der cdu ist und deswegen hat
sie sich jetzt auch geäußert sie hätte
es ja sonst eigentlich gar nicht getan
herr stoss man kennt das ja das soll
zerstritten ist da ganz oben von der spd
die hatte das ja auch jahrelang konnte
die das ja ganz gut und hat ja auch
einige vorsitzende verschlissen wie
schwierig ist es einen wahlkampf zu
machen wenn die partei nicht einig ist
das ist nahezu unmöglich sie können
keinen perfekten wahlkampf machen in
einem solchen zustand und hat die spd ja
auch nicht galt sie hat allerdings
tatsächlich jetzt über zwei jahre dieses
vorsitzenden team und natürlich dann
auch die zusammenarbeit mit olaf scholz
und jetzt seit über einem jahr einen
kanzlerkandidaten das heißt die haben
sich wirklich perfekt darauf vorbereitet
die haben auch im ganz tiefen abgrund
woche geschaut und haben das aber jetzt
tatsächlich bekommen wirklich eine sich
so vorzubereiten dass wenn die anderen
die fehler machen da sie auf dem platz
sind bei der union ist es jetzt
natürlich noch ein ganz anderes problem
ist es wirklich ein zeitfaktor also erst
mal hatten wir jetzt über drei jahre den
kampf um den vorsitz dann hatten wir
diese auseinandersetzung so überlastet
ja schon viel früher begonnen ja im
prinzip war das ja eine
ministerpräsidenten battle zu corona
zeiten wehrmacht zu werden acht auf und
jetzt hatten die union seit dem
zwanzigsten april diesen jahres also ist
fast unvorstellbar an kanzlerkandidaten
und in dieser zeit können sie keine
perfekte kampagne machen die musik sie
können dies nicht richtig vorbereiten
sie brauchen ein team dass ich blind
vertraut das schaffen sie alles in
dieser kürze der zeit nicht das heißt
neben den problemen neben dem ballast
mit ihnen diese kampagne sowieso schon
gestartet ist hat sie eben auch ganz
einfach organisatorische handwerkliche
probleme die man an so vielen ecken
spürt bei den bildern die wir alle
kennen und die natürlich dann zu diesem
strudel geführt haben wir nicht mehr
abreißt aber jetzt auch also jetzt die
die cdu wirft nahezu jeden tag ein neues
thema auf mager so nicht mal ein thema
sondern personen teams dann kommt die
rote socken kann man hier präsentiert
man dann aber wieder ein team das er
eigene roten socken kampagne irgendwie
an wasser abgräbt
und dann kommt noch merkel muss
eingreifen so sehen gar nicht wie sehr
alles es ist eine kampagne im niedergang
ich kenne das ich habe erlebt
und so sieht sie halt auch aus kommen
wir mal zu den machtoptionen also die
frage geben wenn das jetzt schon so
schwierig in der cdu es nicht mehr gut
geht wenn ich jetzt cdu wähle herrscht
reiter was kriege ich denn dann kriege
ich dann laschet uhr plus einem team was
er vorgestellt hat kriege ich auf jeden
fall eine koalition mit der fdp oder
doch schwarz grün woher weiß ich
eigentlich was ich da kriege ich glaube
das weiß niemand und zwar auch niemand
egal was er wählt denn wir haben zum
ersten mal die situation dass es auf wie
es heute aussieht auf jeden fall zu
einer drei parteien koalition kommen
wird wir haben auch zum ersten mal die
situation eigentlich das fünf parteien
unbedingt an der regierung beteiligt
sein wollen das war ja auch nicht immer
so
und das
heißt er wird hoch gepokert und
es kann sein
wir haben das also schon ein paar mal
erlebt dass der wahlsieger des abends
vielleicht doch nicht der wahlsieger ist
weil der der zweitplatzierte
irgendwelche absprachen schon getroffen
hat ja also ich glaube ist zwar nicht
das ist dass solche abfragen jetzt schon
möglich sind aber es kann ja immer
wieder zu überraschungen kommen und
die hatten wir vorhin schon angesprochen
christian lindner wird eine zentrale
rolle spielen und
der tut sicher erkennbar schwer nach
diesem traumatischen erfahrungen mit
denen sie mit den für ihn traumatischen
erfahrungen mit den jamaika
koalitionsverhandlungen der ist kein
freund der grünen ja also der hat immer
das gefühl dass sie bevorzugt werden und
das könnte auch diesmal drohen also ich
glaube christian lindner wird sich
wahnsinnig schwer tun den schritt zu
machen sich sozusagen von laschet
abzuwenden mit dem er ja nordrhein
westfalen mit einer ein-stimmen-mehrheit
super reagiert das wird ihm sehr schwer
fallen und es kann natürlich aber auch
eine überraschung geben es kann
natürlich auch sein wenn ihr zum
beispiel die linkspartei die an jetzt
gerade um 0 5 prozent zum 1 dass sie
plötzlich raus ist und er habe plötzlich
rot grün und dann können die last werden
so viel sie wollen das reicht dann eben
nicht frau riegel wie wichtig ist es für
wähler dass es vorher klar ist mit wem
man koalieren
das war das will ja keiner so richtig
sagen und es ist kompliziert in diesem
jahr spielt das eine rolle bei der
wahlentscheidung
ich denke zumindest für einige wird es
schon eine rolle spielen also man muss
ja nur so in sich selbst hineinhorchen
und man hat vielleicht auch bestimmte
präferenzen und da hätte man doch gerne
sicherheit dass die stimme die man
abgibt wenn sie denn dann auf regierungs
entscheidend ist und das soll sie ja
dort und dann doch hoffentlich dass man
dann auch weiß in welcher konstellation
und vielleicht auch noch ein wort zu der
frage jetzt eben was bekomme ich
eigentlich wenn ich die union wähle zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt also stand jetzt der
umfragen würde ich vermuten wenn die
linke im bundestag ist dass man dann im
besten fall eine starke
oppositionspartei bekommt mit der unions
stimme also das ist ehrlich gesagt der
punkt den ich gerade sehr okay herrscht
aus was denken sie wie wichtig ist es
dass man sich festlegt dass vorher man
vorher sagt mit wem man wie koalieren
will und jetzt im fall der union weil
dass da versucht man ja jetzt klar sagen
ihr müsst die cdu wählen damit nicht die
fdp weil da geht es da gibt es ja auch
befürchtungen dass viele und wo es wäre
ja damals forderte jetzt schon die fdp
auf
zusammenarbeit mit spd und grünen
auszuschließen also ist es immer
unwichtiger geworden in den letzten
jahren muss ich sagen weil wir einfach
diese modelle in allen bundesländern
mittlerweile haben und die menschen
erfahren haben baden württemberg geht
nicht unter mit einem grünen
ministerpräsidenten
bremen geht nicht unter mit einer rot
rot grünen koalition
wir haben alles wir haben jamaika wir
haben ich weiß ja wirklich alles und und
die menschen spüren dass und sie haben
dann tatsächlich jetzt einfach auch
weniger macht mit ihrer stimme das
wissen sie auch die menschen haben sie
ein jahren sie könnten ja einfach die
parteien so stark machen das alleine
reicht oder zu zweit aber im moment ist
es tatsächlich so man weiß es noch
weniger und bei der bei der cdu
muss ich mal sagen wenn das wirklich so
ausgeht wie wir es jetzt sehen dass sie
irgendwo um die 20 prozent landet dann
weiß olaf scholz wahrscheinlich am 27
gar nicht wen er anrufen soll bei der
cdu um um irgendwelche gespräche zu
führen weil dann wird ja laschet nicht
fraktionsvorsitzender
dann kommen einige und cdu noch mal
miteinander also sagen wir so die
machtoption besteht ja zunächst mal wir
haben heute nochmal hainsbach umfrage
reingekriegt die würde tatsächlich für
eine große koalition unter führung der
spd
reichen ich glaube das nicht aber scholz
ist natürlich wir haben ja schon gehört
der der gewieftesten macht techniker von
von allen der will natürlich optionen
haben das ist ja auch der grund warum er
sich bei diesen fragen immer zurück hält
er braucht verhandlungsoptionen er will
sich auch nicht von einem linken
erpressen lassen in einer möglichen
ampelkoalition der muss dann auch sagen
können junge bis hierhin und nicht
weiter herr bolz nach ihrer meinung sie
haben jetzt die drei kanzlerkandidaten
beobachtet aber kennen natürlich auch
christian lindner aus beobachtung würden
sie sagen das ist im moment eigentlich
dann der mächtigste mann der halle also
wenn es auf jeden fall auf eine dreier
koalition hinausläuft ja weil christian
lindner ja also wenn es eine jamaika
koalition oder eine ampelkoalition geben
könnte
theoretisch
ja zumindest
eine eine ganz wichtige rolle eine eine
ganz wichtige rolle spielt weil er
natürlich ein alter weggefährte von
armin laschet ist mit dem er haben wir
eben auch schon gehört
koalitionsverhandlungen erfolgreich in
nordrhein westfalen geführt hat er macht
kein hehl daraus dass er lieber mit
armin laschet und der cdu regieren würde
als mit der spd und mit den grünen und
selbst wenn die spd stärkste partei
werden würde wäre die frage ob christian
lindner da nicht einfach erstmal
verhandlungen mit denen führt aber dann
irgendwann aussteigt um dann mit der cdu
zu verhandeln diese möglichkeit besteht
natürlich immer und die hätte er dann
aber kann sich also kann sich christian
lindner ein aussteigen noch mal erlauben
damals dieses legendäre besser nicht
regieren als falsch zu regieren oder mit
den grünen das nicht machen wollte er
streiter naja hatte ich ja überlebt ich
meine damals er hat damals ist ja sehr
stark kritisiert worden
und jeder hat gesagt das ist das ende
von christian lindner ist es nicht also
im moment bringt er die fdp zu
ungeahnten höhen er oder die freche von
hin lassen wie auch immer aber auf jeden
fall erst der vorsitzende der fdp und
die fdp sammelt stimmen also in den
umfragen stimmen einen wir noch
mittlerweile schon die grünen bedrohen
also das ist ja schon erstaunlich und
das ist für eine komfortable situation
aber wie gesagt ich habe vorhin schon
gesagt das problem ist alle wollen
regieren auch die linke will regieren ja
und
viele leute regen sich darüber auf dass
die union so zu sagen rot-rot-grün als
gespenst an die wand malt das ist nicht
so ein gespenst ja also weil olaf scholz
will auch unbedingt bundeskanzler werden
ja und dafür würde er sehr viel tun ja
und sie würden sagen dafür würde er auch
mit den linken koalieren
er schließt es jedenfalls nicht aus
erschließt es bis heute nicht aus dann
hat er seinen guten grund weil er da die
wähler ein bisschen abfischen möchte und
man soll halt also macht ist ja wie
wasser das fließt halt da hin wo es geht
und
und das wird so ähnlich nach der wahl
sein und vielleicht sind wir alle
überrascht keine ahnung also rot rot
grün ist also rot rot grün ist ja nicht
so geächtet das ist das nicht gäbe es
gibt es in bremen es gibt es in berlin
berlin geht es überhaupt nicht gut aber
es gibt aber es wird natürlich von der
union genutzt also mit dieser roten
socken kampagnen oder aus wie gefährlich
ist es dass das olaf scholz ist das
nicht ausschließt oder was steckt
dahinter würden sie es ihm auch raten
nie ist nicht auszuschliessen ich hätte
ihm geraten wir schauen mal was passiert
nach dem tristen tree l und es passierte
nichts
das heißt die rote socken kampagne ist
seit zwei wochen auf dem markt und ist
gefloppt und
deshalb hat er eigentlich kein anlass er
hat allerdings etwas gemacht was ich
sehr clever fand in zusammenarbeit mit
fresken dass sie eigentlich zuerst die
kriterien definiert hat warum das mit
den linken nicht gehen das heißt das war
natürlich ein starkes signal ihnen die
linke der spd dass diese kriterien von
ascon kommen nicht voran stolz sehr
clever macht man nur wenn man eine gut
eingearbeitete kampagne hat und dadurch
ist es faktisch ausgeschlossen der
andere grund ist
die menschen trauern scholz einfach
nicht zu dass er mist baut die trauen
ihm einfach nicht zu dass er mit ihrer
stimme etwas macht was nicht gut für
deutschland ist und das ist eigentlich
genau der punkt war dass alle heißen
heißen eine koalition mit den linken
wäre mist für deutschland ich glaube
dsds wäre die leute trauen ihm nicht zu
dass er irgendetwas schlechtes macht so
also das heißt dass er dass er mit
dieser stimme nicht mit diesen mandaten
nicht verantwortungsbewusst um kann dann
kann ich das auch gleich nicht für
deutschland teurer waren als ich bin
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich angewandt weil
wir wie gesagt ja schon sehr viele
koalitionsmodelle irgendwo hatten und
wie gesagt als ich zum letzten mal in
thüringen nachgeschaut dort stand auch
noch also
bitte ich würde das unterstützen wollen
was er gesagt hat und man darf auch
nicht vergessen die spd hat einen
parteitagsbeschluss aus dem jahr 2013 wo
sie ganz dezidiert gesagt hat die
ausschließeritis abgesehen von
rechtspopulistischen parteien hat ein
ende das heißt wir können theoretisch
auch mit den linken koalieren und sie
hat das an drei bedingungen geknüpft und
eine dieser drei bedingungen war die
bedingungen die auch jetzt wieder
genannt wird nämlich eine stabile
außenpolitik innerhalb der nato
und genau das hat olaf scholz jetzt auch
wieder gesagt und wenn er jetzt
plötzlich sagen würde dieser
parteitagsbeschluss geht nicht mehr dass
das würde natürlich auch nicht gehen und
deswegen schließt er ist auch nicht aus
er sagt aber auch ganz klar mit einer
partei die die nato ablehnt werde ich
nicht regieren so und da kann sich dann
jeder seinen reim drauf machen also ich
finde die haltung in dem punkt von olaf
scholz eigentlich relativ
nachvollziehbar frau riedel was denken
sie wie wichtig ist dann die oder wie
sinnvoll ist dann diese kampagne der cdu
oder dass die bundeskanzlerin auch noch
mal vor so ein linksbündnis warnt wenn
man das wenn man denkt ja falls wurde
das sowieso nicht machen
ich meine in anbetracht der
gesamtsituation für die union ist es
nachvollziehbar dass man also versucht
vor also den roten socken zu warnen und
versucht auch die spd und auch damit
letztlich olaf scholz so ein rotes
schreckgespenst darzustellen aber wir
sehen es verfängt nicht das hatten die
vorredner jetzt eben auch gesagt also es
kommt einfach nicht an und das liegt
eben auch daran weil olaf scholz nicht
taugt als eine sozusagen linksaußen
figur innerhalb der spd das funktioniert
nicht und da ist der punkt ich denke
dieses diese zurückhaltung mit blick auf
ein explizites ausschließen einer
koalition mit den linken hat einmal was
mit den parteibeschluss zu tun
andererseits ist es aber auch
strategisch klug also dass man einfach
wählerstimmen nicht sozusagen droht also
ich auszuschließen zu verlieren und wir
wissen es die parteien sind gerade alle
auf stimmenfang peking ist das thema
jetzt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt und
insofern ist macht er eigentlich an der
stelle alles richtig und einen weiteren
punkt den ich im grunde auch noch ein
bisschen vermute also eben wurde ja auch
schon gesagt dass das christian lindner
vielleicht auch so eine schlüsselfigur
bei der regierungsbildung
koalitionsbildung spielen könnte meine
vermutung ist dass olaf scholz an der
stelle natürlich auch etwas gut daran
tut die linken nicht ganz auszuschließen
um potenziell in sondierungen
koalitionsverhandlungen damit nimmt ein
bisschen unter druck setzen können also
in dem sinne ich habe ja noch eine
andere alternative wenn du nicht willst
dass man sozusagen länder so muss dann
so verantwortlich sein um das land vor
einem linken bündnis zu bewahren das
wäre dann wichtig wäre ich noch eine
schöne ausrede ehrenherr ausrede um geld
aber ihrem wasser
spiegel interview übrigens genau so
formuliert dass er die ja deutschland
vor einem linksbündnis bewahren muss
wenn ich das richtig gelesen jetzt hat
armin laschet ja gestern in der debatte
gesagt man kann nicht mit der raute
durch die gegend laufen und dann reden
wie das fiasko also die cdu ärgert sich
dass olaf scholz so tut als könne als
wäre er der neue merkel herrscht reiter
ist er das hat er da ähnlichkeiten mit
der kanzlerin der hat man ja immer
vorgeworfen sie sehr sozialdemokratisch
sind die viel näher als man denkt na ja
also er versucht und ich meine also ich
eher sprich die emotionen anja er beruft
sich zum beispiel auf helmut schmidt
gegen den er früher auf die straße
gegangen ist er macht die raute also
eigentlich war ja gedacht dass armin
laschet die männliche kopie von angela
merkel ist und jetzt haben wir eine
zweite kopie und er versucht jetzt
sozusagen die bessere kopie zu sein ja
und das ist schon verblüffend und es
fängt ja teilweise auch ja also er
machte so den ruf in wahrheit macht eher
wenig also sie sind beide sowohl laschet
wie schaut's sind in den schlafwagen
eingestiegen und haben gedacht wir
warten mal ab
dann haben sie sich den falschen gegner
ausgesucht das waren die grünen haben
frau berbalk attackiert von beiden
seiten was ihr auch massiv geschadet hat
und
und dann ging der schlafwagen weiter und
dann kam plötzlich die das hochwasser in
nordrhein-westfalen und da musste armin
laschet aussteigen aus diesem
schlafwagen und scholz konnte weiter
rumpeln ja und da ist armin laschet aus
der deckung gegangen dann hat er mal an
der falschen stelle gelacht dann hat er
mal irgendwie ein eis gegessen oder er
hat die falschen schuhe angehabt das ist
alles mit einem hohen versöhnungs und
verhetzung potenzial durch die sozialen
medien getrieben worden an oder scholz
bleibt gar nichts hängen und das ist das
was mich wundert ja ich meine er hat ein
massives problem in hamburg mit diesem
mit seinem lieblings banker dem 90
millionen euro vj schenken wollte das
ist aber zu kompliziert um zu erklären
ja oder es ist man kann es nicht in
einem satz erklären und das verstehen
die leute nicht also halten sich lieber
daran auf dass armin laschet fünf
sekunden gelacht hat und das ist für die
union an sich ein großes problem
erstaunt dass super finden weil
natürlich bilder mehr sagen als tausend
worte und man kommt halt mit 1000 worten
dagegen nicht aus der eu sieht aber
könnte der staat könnte denn jetzt wenn
man sagt er der schweiz konnte kann
schon im schlafwagen sitzen bleiben also
kann der auch noch auf den letzten
zweieinhalb wochen kann da auch noch
irgendwas kommen wo sich das einfach
dann noch mal wirklich umdreht nein der
große unterschied zwischen ihm und
laschet und auch frau werbung ist ja
dass urlaub so lange schon ein top spot
in der deutschen politik hat als
zweifach gewählter ministerpräsident
beziehungsweise erster bürgermeister von
hamburg als sozial und arbeitsminister
als vizekanzler als finanzminister die
menschen haben armin laschet nicht
gekannt das ist ein trugschluss der der
union oval ministerpräsident von
nordrhein westfalen ist kennen die leute
nicht und schon gar nicht in dem
medienzirkus zyklus centers oder zirkus
in dem wir heutzutage leben das heißt
die leute kannten wieder herr laschet
noch frau werburg und die beiden
durchlaufen jetzt diesen test und alle
fehler die sie machen denn bei ihnen
doppelt und dreifach so stark
wahrgenommen wie bei einem olaf scholz
wo man sagt na ja der hat vielleicht
auch mal seine fehler gemacht aber im
grunde kenne ich den mann seit 20 jahren
und ich traue ihm einfach nicht zu dass
er ein bock schießt wieder im kanzleramt
sitzt und die die frage jetzt die sie
diese aufgeworfen hatten hier mit mit
hamburg ich kenne ich habe drei
wahlkämpfe in hamburg und macht der wird
seit seit jahren wird er jedes blatt
fünf mal umgedreht und sie finden halt
einfach nix und vielleicht ist halt auch
einfach nichts da und das ist halt auch
eine lehre die da passieren kann wir
sind jetzt so nah dran wir sind
zweieinhalb wochen davor es ist eigene
name auch schon gemacht viele haben
schon gewählt und es gibt auch ein
endpunkt wo überhaupt irgendetwas noch
einfluss auf eine wahl hat wenn es nicht
gerade
fukushima ist und diesen punkt nähen wir
uns jeden tag selbst wenn eine woche vor
der wahl noch irgendwas größeres
passieren würde wissen wir wirklich dass
das eigentlich nahezu keinen einfluss
mehr die leute haben sich ihre meinung
gebildet obwohl sehr viele
unentschlossene und ich haben ja das ist
auch wieder weniger als vier jahre und
eine kleine sache ist natürlich auch
noch ganz ganz wichtig weil es wieder
auf die tri elle und kann man da noch
was die leute gehen ja jetzt schon mit
einer extrem negativen meinungen über
armin laschet in diese tree elle rein
das heißt sie schaut eigentlich schon
mit einer voreingenommenheit zu und das
heißt der mann müsste ich eigentlich
dreifach gewinnen herum um das wasser zu
drehen reden wir mal über die grünen
aber die haben nämlich noch gar nicht
geredet am anfang sind ja die drei
kandidaten und wir gehen es reden immer
über laschet und stolz und denken gar
nicht mehr daran dass frau berbalk das
auch noch schaffen könnte wo hätte denn
wenn wir über die macht reden herr bolz
wo hätte den ihrer meinung nach frau
bernburg die meiste möglichkeit ihre
position noch durchzusetzen
also jetzt als regierungschef von oder
in einer koalition wo sie
minderheitspartner wäre also in der
koalition weil ich jetzt glaube dass man
darf also nicht einfach nicht stärkste
kraft würde das ist eine interessante
frage also dass beide sagen ja also
sowohl spd dass sie gerne mit sowohl
grüne als auch spd dass sie gerne
miteinander koalieren wollen wenn es
eine dreier konstellation wäre
könnten die grünen natürlich in einer
koalition in einer jamaika-koalition mit
einer relativ schwachen cdu unter
umständen viel mehr durchsetzen als in
einer ampelkoalition mit einer relativ
starken spd also insofern ist auch dass
für die grünen letztlichen
abwägungsprozess wo kann ich mehr
durchsetzen das wäre meiner meinung nach
wahrscheinlich in einer
jamaika-koalition was gegen eine ampel
sprechen würde nichtsdestotrotz glaube
ich würden sie die präferieren
ok frau riedel was würden sie sagen wo
sehen die grünen sich was was denken sie
wie das in welche richtung die nach nach
der nach der wahl operieren werden
ja ich habe gerade auch so ein bisschen
drüber nachgedacht also in der koalition
mit der union und mit der fdp da sind im
grunde die größten unterschiede mit
blick auf die grünen hinsichtlich
finanzpolitische themen sozialer
politischer themen auch ein rundum thema
wohnen ist ein bisschen eine andere
ausrichtung also da müssten sie
sicherlich abstriche machen aber klar
wenn die union sehr schwach ist würde
das den grünen an der stelle vielleicht
ein bisschen entgegenkommen in einer
koalition mit der spd da hätte man den
vorteil dass man gerade bei den
sozialpolitischen themen auch bei den
finanzpolitischen zum teil ein bisschen
näher ist und da ist dann eben die frage
ob es dann mit der fdp
mit der fdp oder mit der linken also bei
der linken das muss ich ehrlich sagen
ist so eine koalitionskonstellationen
die ich an der stelle nicht ernsthaft
als politisch realistisch sehe insofern
spd grüne und fdp und ich glaube da
würde sich die würden sich die grünen
schon ganz wohl fühlen können würden sie
wohl fühlen können aber man hat ja lange
hat man so gesagt schwarz grüne es wäre
schon mal die zeit das land anders
regiert würde schwarz grün wäre so das
neue bündnis wie realistisch ist es noch
ich halte es nicht für völlig
unrealistisch ist war ich mal meine alte
these dass ja also sowohl die union wie
auch große teile der grünen vom gefühl
her konservativ sind die einen weil die
natur bewahren die anderen nennen
schöpfung
da lässt sich schon was machen und
dazu wäre es allerdings erforderlich
dass armin laschet es schafft irgendwie
überhaupt die cdu-anhänger mal an die
wahlurne zu bringen
und da kommt es dann doch also ich
glaube dass eine angeschlagene cdu die
irgendwie in gespräche überhaupt kommt
mit mit den grünen und mit der fdp
die ist natürlich aus grünen sicht ist
da viel mehr zu erreichen weil ja die
cdu auch schwach ist und weil sie
natürlich eine hohe potenzial haben und
sagen ergeben zum olaf und
also und ich glaube dass die cdu
angesichts eines drohenden machtverlust
es zu kompromissen bereit sind die wir
uns heute noch gar nicht ausmachen
können die sie aber lernen ja mit der
fdp auch hinkriegen muss
aber das ist das letzte schalker
die erste jamaika verhandlung sind ja
laut lindner an frau merkel gescheitert
weil er sich
wenn man das gefühl hatte dass sie die
grünen mehr mag als ihnen und da habe
ich ja jetzt entfallen und es stimmt
dass
das kann schon sein also
da spricht einiges dafür jedenfalls wenn
man das nimmt was die leute damals
berichtet haben aber ganz ehrlich ich
halte das wirklich für nahezu
ausgeschlossen weil die grünen haben wir
nun auch noch eine basis und da gibt es
einerseits natürlich die
wertkonservativen die sind mal gerne in
baden württemberg und die regieren da
auch aber ansonsten ist das ja eine viel
stärker in richtung umweltschutz
klimaschutz da zusammen zu kommen mit
einer fdp ist schon schwierig genug da
brauchen die grünen eigentlich eher noch
die spd die dann in die gleiche richtung
drängt wenn es aber noch eine cdu dabei
ist die dann wenn sie überhaupt in
dieser situation kommt ja auch noch
friedrich merz irgendwo unterbringen
muss dem team team unter unterwegs ist
der natürlich wiederum rotes tuch für
die grünen ist mit all seinen
kulturellen differenzen von gender und
abwärts und einwanderungspolitik und so
weiter und so fort das heißt laschet hat
ja jetzt einen einen hardcore
konservativen wie märz holen müssen
obwohl er eigentlich angetreten ist als
liberaler unionskandidat um genau diese
schwarz grüne option zu eröffnen das hat
er jetzt wieder zurücknehmen müssen um
seine basis zu konsolidieren ich wie
gesagt wer mal abwarten müssen wenn sich
das so bewahrheitet was da gerade
passiert was von der cdu jetzt auch an
führungspersonal überhaupt noch übrig
bleibt nach dieser wahl da sie ja zum
teil noch sehr düster aus in den an den
landesverbänden weil den direktwahl
kandidaten der fliegt viel raus an
erfahrung auch wie gesagt sie hat diese
lange phase jetzt der vorsitzenden suche
gehabt dass in die wunden noch nicht
verheilt er wieder grüßt aus münchen und
herr laschet kann sich nicht halten er
muss dann auch wieder eventuell zurück
nach nordrhein westfalen hat roth an die
nächste landtagswahl also das sieht
alles alles sehr volatil aus wo ich sage
vielleicht ist ja im moment die cdu das
größte risiko als koalitionspartner aber
gar nicht weiß wie die sich noch mal
zusammen für wenn das so ist frau riedel
wenn die cdu so schwach es ist das ein
punkt wo man sagt dadurch stärkt man
auch zb die 11
also wir sehen uns ja gerade so ein
bisschen in den umfragen dass es
zumindest zum jetzigen zeitpunkt scheint
dass es vor allen dingen die fdp mit
stärkt also dass dahin so ein bisschen
die stimmung hin wandert das ist die afg
stärkt das würde ich zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt so noch nicht sagen also so
insgesamt sehen wir eigentlich dass die
afd nicht wirklich punkten kann in den
wahlkampf und und da auch nicht sich
sozusagen als
alternative hinstellen kann also den
punkt sehe ich an sich an der stelle
nicht nein dann kommen wir mal zu den
persönlichkeiten weil das hat ja viel
auch damit zu tun gerade wenn sie in
koalitionen geht wer mit wem wirklich
kann über lindner haben wir ja schon
gesprochen jetzt heißt es ja immer mehr
streit herr laschet ist so jemand der so
integriert der so menschen
zusammenbringt und so ist das nicht dann
auch noch ein pfund mit dem er wuchern
kann weil sein ego vielleicht nicht ganz
so groß ist wie das von olaf scholz das
ist ein pfund also ich bin ja auch
rheinländer und ich kann mir eigentlich
auch also es ja das ist aber auch sein
problem nicht also die grenze zwischen
unverbindlichkeit und
und der fähigkeit zu versöhnen
zusammenzubringen die ich ja fließend
und nicht jeder findet das gut und
manche sagen das sei beliebig ich finde
es nicht er hat er ist auch in diesen
dingen eigentlich bisher immer
unterschätzt worden und wenn er fit
bleibt und wenn er sage ich mal noch ein
bisschen zulegt dann wird eben wird ihm
das schon helfen ja und aber das ist ja
auch ein kompromiss fähiger und
kompromissbereiter mensch das heißt die
sind sich und sich ähnlich und
wer ist dann besser macht wird sich dann
herausstellen ja also wer ist jetzt mehr
in der lage
ein bisschen strippen zu ziehen und mal
vertrauliche gespräche zu führen und
leute zusammenzubringen von denen man
vielleicht gedacht hat dass sie gar
nicht zusammenpassen
glaube ich hat la isla scheint ein
bisschen ein bisschen fähiger dazu weil
er das länger eingeübt hat aber da würde
ich jetzt aber auch wiederum scheußlich
unterschätzen herr bolz aus der
beobachtung der drei kandidaten bei von
ihnen was würden sie sagen wer hat er
die beste möglichkeit also die sie haben
das größte marktgespür hat olaf scholz
ihrer meinung nach aber die frage so wie
bringt man leute zusammen ist wie
kompromissfähig ist man wie wie schafft
man es ja letztendlich sind es ja dann
nachtsitzung und wo man zusammensitzt
und irgendwie dieses diese koalition
schmieden muss zudem würden sie da das
bei meister zu trauen also ich glaube
olaf scholz hat wahrscheinlich mit
nachsetzen am meisten erfahrungen weil
das hat er in der bundesregierung ja
sehr häufig durchexerzieren müssen und
auch im koalitionsausschuss er hat auch
hier in hamburg die rot grüne koalition
die er hier hatte glaube ich sehr gut
geführt also das war glaube ich ein
relativ gutes miteinander
aber ich sehe es genauso das auch armin
laschet diese qualität natürlich
mitbringt die betont er auch immer
wieder die hat er auch bei mir im
interview als eine seiner stärken betont
dass er halt eben auch seinen kleinen
koalitionspartnern raum lassen will
beziehungsweise jetzt momentan ja der
fdp in düsseldorf raum lässt auch
stärken zu zeigen und eben auch punkte
zu machen was ganz wichtig ist was die
fdp merkel ja immer vorgeworfen hat das
sieht es eben nicht gemacht hat sind in
der westerwälder ehre
und insofern glaube ich die beiden
können das gleichermaßen gut bei
annalena baerbock ist das natürlich ein
moment den es noch nicht gibt auf der
politischen landkarte oder im
politischen leben dass sie eine
regierung führen muss und damit dann
auch kompromisse schließen muss und all
diese ganzen dinge das hat sie halt noch
nicht gemacht das muss man auch einfach
so sehen vor wie stark schätzen sie der
annalena baerbock ein wirklich die
position der grünen dann da
durchzusetzen oder muss das dann doch
robert habeck machen der sich ja damit
christian lindner die ja beide
finanzminister werden dann haben sie ja
schon gesagt
ja genau also genau wie bei den punkt
habe ich jetzt auch gerade noch mal
nachgedacht wer streitet jetzt darum wer
finanzminister werden darf lindner oder
ahlbeck und es wird schon gesagt
annalena baerbock konnte diese
eigenschaft von die sie vielleicht ja
auch hat bisher nicht zeigen bei laschet
und und scholz steht es außer frage dass
sie das potenzial die fähigkeiten haben
und auch die erfahrung haben leute an
einen tisch zu bringen und man insofern
beiden zutraut auch schwere
koalitionsverhandlungen zu führen bei
annalena baerbock ich würde jetzt
einfach mal auch aus dem bauch heraus
vermuten dass sie sich sicherlich
unterstützung holen wird und ich kann
mir auch gut vorstellen dass robert
habeck da ja nun auch
regierungserfahrung hat das der da
sicherlich auch eine rolle spielen wird
herr staus bei und hinzu kommt ja dass
anna lena bei
dass annalena baerbock ja bei den
verhandlungen 2017 ja schon auch mit am
tisch war also ganz so grün ist sie dann
vielleicht auch noch nicht hinter den
ohren mehr staus auf was kommt es an bei
solchen verhandlungen dass man sagt wer
sich dann letztendlich durchsetzt wäre
das bessere sitz deutschland
das gehört auf jeden fall dazu also ich
werde das nicht
ich muss allerdings auch sagen wenn
olaf scholz der schon arbeits und
sozialminister war da auch schon viele
nachtsitzungen hatte finanzminister ich
kann auf jeden fall eines sagen ich
glaube unter einem bundeskanzler olaf
scholz arbeits und sozialminister oder
finanzminister zu sein ist in keinem
fall vergnügungssteuerpflichtig weil er
diesen jobs einfach in und auswendig
kennt und da natürlich auch vielleicht
das ein oder andere mal
das gefühl hat dann müsste dann mal
mitregieren aber klar es geht am ende um
um macht wir haben vorhin gesprochen
über die über die kanzlerin die die
würde in solchen bereichen der
mittlerweile fast zu heiligen erklärt
wir haben erlebt wenn es drauf ankommt
macht sie macht politik und hat sie
immer gemacht und wären nicht 16 jahre
unsere unsere kanzlerin gewesen darum
geht es am ende und es geht aber
natürlich auch immer darum dass man das
was man jetzt angekündigt hatten das ist
wegen glaube ich auch die grünen am ende
natürlich doch zur spd gehen werden weil
sie einfach sehen sie es sind so viele
gemeinsamkeiten und natürlich müsste man
jetzt im wahlkampf noch mal noch einmal
thematisieren aber der weg von einer von
den von den grünen jetzt in eine
koalition mit union und fdp das halte
ich wirklich für für nahezu
ausgeschlossen
es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere
alternativen über die werde da nicht
gesprochen und gibt ja auch noch cdu und
grüne gemeinsam unter einem kanzler
scholz cdu und fdp gemeinsam unter
scholz also im moment ist einfach er die
frage es gibt nur eine machtoption für
laschet und deswegen reden wir darüber
gerade aber wie gesagt wenn er mit dem
ergebnis nach hause kommt dann gibt es
sowieso keine machtoption für für
irgendjemanden in der union dann wird es
schon noch mal bitte herr streiter jetzt
nächsten sonntag nochmal tree l da setzt
die union noch mal stark drauf sagt das
muss jetzt noch mal bringen was würden
sie eine lasche raten jetzt soll er da
auftreten
er soll so auftreten wie er ist er soll
es soll vielleicht ein bisschen scharf
attackieren er muss polarisieren ja das
ist eine einzige chance er muss klar
machen dass er
dass er doch nicht so langweilig ist wie
urlaub ist ja das ist eine einzige
chance und das schöne ist ja natürlich
muss man eines sagen und so als
versöhnlicher abschluss vielleicht wir
leben ja in einer
super komfortablen situation denn in
wahrheit ist also weder wenn armin
laschet noch wenn oder chance selbst
wenn frau bergmann bundeskanzlerin
werden würde müssten wir alle nicht
auswandern in deutschland würde nicht
untergehen und das unterscheidet uns von
vielen vielen ländern in der welt ok
dann nehmen wir das mal als also ich
würde wirklich etwas anderes raten die
muss das nur kurz sagen weil er steht
unter druck seiner partei jetzt
anzugreifen und zu attackieren da sie so
jetzt müssen wir erst recht ich glaube
er müsste die zeit nutzen um für sich zu
werben und nicht um andere zu
attackieren vielleicht also ist das
große problem dass er gesagt die partei
erwartet die attacke aber die zuschauer
wohl eigentlich umworben werden okay das
ist hier bei den drei handbold frau
riedel und verständlich da glaube ich
eigentlich vielen dank ganz herzlichen
dank nach hamburg und münchen liegen
herzlichen dank hier ihnen vielen dank
fürs zuschauen morgen sind wir wieder
für sie da und dann reden wir über das
thema migration in europa bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]